Russia's state media tonight
going to great lengths
to try to promote Putin's,
comparing him to a rock star,
literally just days
after facing the biggest threat ever
to his presidency.
This
creek, if he has got screaming,
squealing, applause,
literally pleas for photos with him.
The president was greeted in such a way
that even rock stars have nothing on him.
Rock stars.
Nick Paton Walsh is OUTFRONT with more on
how Putin is trying to reassert
that macho image he's so known for inside
Russia.
What's a strong man
when he's no longer that strong?
Just a guy on a horse who needs a shirt
We've been so accustomed
to these images of Vladimir Putin
as some sort of super man
manipulating the known world
in a genius game of
five dimensional chess
and wrestling
his opponents to the mat intellectually.
Now the world is coming to terms
with a completely new concept
A weak
Putin
who seems
almost to play the clown here today
at a trade fair,
making a sketch,
living in a parallel reality
from the near collapse of the weekend
while the weekend's armed
rebellion by his former confidant
Prigozhin failed.
It had one catastrophic success.
Bursting the bubble
of Putin's and ability
the Kremlin hat
didn't even appear in public
for two
and a half days,
popping up
only outside the Kremlin Tuesday
to deliver a surreal
thank you to the military
who'd step back and let partner
march on Moscow.
Putin is now in a place
he's never been before.
Hunting for traitors in his inner circle,
he was said to have isolated himself
so much during the pandemic,
keeping visitors at a distance
that perhaps
he no longer
can find his way back down the table
to reality.
The Moscow elite's
gentle
bubble of assured
autocracy has also been burst.
It is a place where riches were earned
through unquestioning loyalty.
But now, after the Ukraine invasion,
contends with drones
attacking luxury suburbs
and even the Kremlin Putin.
None of this was meant to happen.
None of this is what Putin sold Russia.
But none of this could be easily
answered by a strong man
who no longer seems strong
Now you can see
how Putin is clearly still at the task
of trying to remind
Russia how popular he is
with those remarkable displays.
But you have to also ask yourself,
how quickly
is he dealing with
the ultimate challenges
of working out,
frankly, what to do with Prigozhin
or even where he is,
and whether or not there is genuine
dissent still inside his military.
And that's the crucial question.
I fear he will not live
with the paranoia.
Nick, thank you very much.